بعد الزلزال القوي اللي ضرب سوريا وتركيا
في سته فبراير صار في حاله هلع كبيره وقلق
شبه دائم خوفا من حدوث زلزال اقوى في
المستقبل القريب خاصه مع كثره التنبؤات
والكلام امس الساعه ثمانيه واربع دقائق
مساء بالتوقيت المحلي سجل جنوب التركي
زلزال جديد بقوه 6.4 درجات وبعده بدقائق
زلزال ثاني بقوه 5.8 درجات وطبعا زاد
الرعب ورجعت فيديوهات لحظه الهلع التمل
للمنصات
[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الزلزال ضرب محافظه هاتاي وقتل 6 اشخاص
كمان انهارت مباني من اللي كانت تضررت من
زلزال 6 فبراير تركيا اعلنت انه ثلاثه من
الوفيات كانوا اشخاص رجعوا لشققهم المدمره
من الزلزال الاول عشان يجيبوا مقتنيات لما
وقع الزلزال الجديد وانهارت المباني عليهم
وحذرت السلطات الناس من جديد انه تزور
بيوتها
المتهالكه الزلزال الجديد هذا يعتبر هزه
ارتداديه لزلزال سته فبراير وبعده ضربت
المنطقه 90 هزه ارتداديه واحده منها بقوه
5.8 وهذه الهزات شعر فيها مواطنين في
لبنان في سوريا في قبرص كمان الخوذ
البيضاء في حلب اتكلم عن 150 اصابه بجروح
بسبب الزلزال
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
العالم كله ظاهر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]